تاج وصول جناني وكره ذهبيه هذه من الرموز
الملكيه التي تسمى بالرجاليا تستخدم خلال
مراسم تتويج الملك تشارز الثالث هذه
الاشياء ترمز الى جوانب مختلفه من
مسؤوليات الملك ومنصبه التاج الامبراطوري
يستخدم فقط عند تتويج الملك التاج مرصع
باحجار ثمينه ويزن اكثر من كيلوغرامين
الصولجان الملكيان مرصعان بالاحجار
الكريمه والميناء الاول عليه ماسه تعرف
باسم نجمه افريقيا التي اقتطعت من اكبر
ماسه في العالم ويرمز للقوه والعداله
الملكيه والثاني يعرف بصولجان العداله
والرحمه ويرمز للدور الروحاني للملك الكره
الذهبيه الملكيه مرصعه بحزام من الاحجار
الكريمه واللؤ مراسم هذا الحفل التاريخي
تتكون من مراحل عده تبدا بالاقرار حيث يتم
تقديم الملك الى الحضور وتنتهي بجلوسه على
العرش ليصبح الملك الاربعين في تاريخ
المملكه المتحده